oh my gosh
um I'm such a fan I'm so hot have y'all
ever met no no no okay only in my dreams
yeah exactly I know y'all both look
really rock and roll right now so I'm
just living the vibe that you're
portraying right now but gosh we're
going like the Best Funeral Ever
[Laughter]
um you started writing when you were on
Glee but I heard that nobody really knew
that you were writing no because I was
always really kind of secretive about it
like I would write you know in sets that
weren't being used while we were
shooting and I remember we were doing
this huge obnoxious world tour at one
point and um I would really liked it it
was yeah um and I would like I would
crawl underneath the stage and like I
would write like during the show and
after the show before the show and uh
yeah it was it was a crazy time because
like we go out we'd Sing Don't Stop
Believing and I go I write down a
sentence I'd then go strap on a leotard
do the Single Ladies dance and then run
back out and it's like a normal day that
ends
right A Tuesday that's cool though I
like the idea of creating while you're
doing something but it's different I
love that people are that creative and
can create that thank you very cool
thank you so much um this is the 10th
anniversary of the Land of Stories so
for people who haven't read the books
what are they about so uh in a nutshell
uh they're about a pair of brother
sister twins named Alex and Connor and
they inherit a magic storybook that
takes them into the fairy tale World
um and over the course of the series
they have adventures with all the fairy
tale characters we know and love and
characters from classic literature and
also characters and worlds from their
own creative writing and along the way
they help each other more in the loss of
their father and so there's been six
books in the main series and I just
finished writing the prequel series
about their grandparents which was three
books so yeah yeah and me too it's easy
yeah I have a prequel more than a sequel
I do too yeah I like I like figuring out
like how people got I'm like wait we're
gonna figure out what happened and why I
got there I think that's so so clever
yeah it was a lot of fun right thank you
so much like Chris this is an amazing
book I just wanted to say that because
it really is cool like reading with my
kids and like really enjoying it I'm so
happy it's so good and it's such an
interesting thing to go from being loved
is like this character and people know
you in a different light to know you
also have this whole other Talent going
on oh thank you I'm just so fortunate
that I was a I was given the
opportunities to to to do all this stuff
so I'm very very lucky well I'm going to
tell you I we don't we can edit this out
because I know we're at a time but I
actually heard of your book whenever I
was um I was working through like um
deals like of like what I was going to
do because I wanted to write children's
books or whatever and I and I did and
one of the companies I met with was like
oh my God there's this this artist we
love that we've worked with and he's
actually they introduced me in that
meeting two-year series oh my God it
wasn't even like at a store they
literally were like hey there's this
thing you might be interested in I
literally read the wishing spell like
right oh my gosh and I thought it was
just so good so I just wanted you to say
please don't cut that out no I just
no but I just wanted I wanted to tell
you that your team loves what you're
doing yeah yeah well the 10th
anniversary edition of The Land of
Stories the wishing spell is out now
complete with new illustrations and Maps
which is exciting and everyone is going
home with a copy
of putting pins of paper I have some
exciting news our season long partner
pilot pin is once again hosting their
100 000 G2 overachievers Grant and the
fifteen thousand dollar G2 overachiever
student grant a true overachiever is
someone who goes above and beyond their
everyday responsibilities to improve
their community and the world pilot
wants to honor those overachievers and
give them the recognition and money they
deserve handwritten nominations for both
grants must be submitted by December
31st 2022 and next year the finalists
might be featured right here on the show
we love this and to G2 overachievers.com
to find out how to apply don't miss out
on this opportunity you have no idea how
you can impact someone's lives
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]